the Leo Bernett advertising agency
conceived the Mayhem ads and in 2011
Bernette Executive Vice President nah
abne told at AG that one of their main
goals was to quote kick Flo's ass she
was speaking about all state rival
progressives extremely popular
advertising mascot thanks in part to the
flow ads all State's market share had
dropped for two straight years the
previous ad campaign was pretty
unmemorable with actor Dennis hayesburg
calmly and seriously reminding TV
viewers of the importance of insurance
the Mayhem campaign reversed all states
fortunes with Winter's character adding
an emphasis on value over price after
all Mayhem frequently belittles Cut Rate
Insurance and the fools who buy
it what a hit and if you have Cut Rate
car insurance the cost to cover that
might tank your season